Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Our observations had taught us to conceive a spectacle exceeding our original expectations, but they had not prepared us for the extent and display of the scene which here burst upon us. An area nearly a mile in circumference was crowded with magnificence and novelty. At least a hundred large umbrellas or canopies which could shelter thirty persons were sprung up and down by the bearers with brilliant effect. The superior captains in attendance wore a shanty cloth of extravagant price.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们的观察曾让我们预见到一番超乎最初预期的壮观景象，但对于眼前这场爆发开来的宏大与奢华场面，我们依然始料未及。一片将近一英里周长的区域内挤满了华丽与新奇。至少有一百把大伞或华盖——大到足以容纳三十人——被抬伞者们熟练地撑上撑下，效果极为惊艳。随行的各位高级将领身着价值不菲的山地布。
These were of incredible size and weight, and thrown over the shoulder exactly like a Roman toga. A small silk fillet generally encircled their temples, and massy gold necklaces intricately wrought suspended Moorish charms. Gold and silver pipes and canes called the eye in every direction. Wolves and ram's heads as large as life, life cast in gold were suspended from their gold handled swords so that tom holland was t.e bowditch who was the first englishman to leave a written account of the court of the king of ashanti after his visit in may 1817 and we're in the middle of our great world cup odyssey, aren't we, through the countries that have qualified for the tournament in Qatar. We are talking about the Ashanti Kingdom. So this
这些衣物尺寸和重量惊人，像古罗马托加袍一样直接搭在肩上。他们的太阳穴周围通常环绕着一条细小的丝绸饰带，做工复杂的厚重金项链上则悬挂着摩尔人的护身符。金银烟斗和手杖在各个方向吸引着人们的目光。像真狼头和公羊头一样大小、用黄金铸造的头像挂在他们金柄的剑上，因此托马斯·鲍迪奇（Tom Holland 注：此处播客口误将鲍迪奇与汤姆·霍兰德混淆，指特德·鲍迪奇 T. E. Bowditch）——他是第一位在1817年5月拜访后留下关于阿散蒂国王朝廷书面记载的英国人——我们正处于伟大世界杯奥德赛的中途，对吧？穿越那些获得卡塔尔世界杯参赛资格的国家。我们在谈论阿散蒂王国。所以这
is the episode for Tom? For Ghana. For Ghana. And I will confess right away that I know genuinely nothing at all about this subject. So I'm greatly looking forward to being educated, Tom, are you? Well, I'm not going to pretend that I am in any way a specialist in the study of the Ashanti Empire either. Actually, ever since I read Dan Morris's book, Heaven's Command, which describes the British expeditions against this extraordinary empire in what is now Ghana, Ashanti land. And I guess the Ashanti are probably up there with the Zulus as the African empire that most impressed the British. And because the British tended to write the earliest reports, they're a kind of very vivid record. Today is Ghana. And as you will know ghana is
是专属于汤姆的一集？为了加纳。为了加纳。我得马上承认，我对这个主题真的完全一无所知。所以我非常期待能长长见识，汤姆，你呢？好吧，我可不会假装自己在研究阿散蒂帝国方面是什么专家。实际上，自从我读了丹·莫里斯（Dan Morris 注：实际为詹姆斯·莫里斯 James Morris）的书《天堂的命令》（Heaven's Command）之后——书中描述了英国人针对这个位于现今加纳（阿散蒂兰）的非凡帝国的远征。我想阿散蒂大概和祖鲁人一样，是最令英国人印象深刻的非洲帝国。而且因为英国人往往撰写最早的报告，所以它们留下了非常生动的记录。今天的加纳。正如你所知，加纳是
the oldest football association in africa 1920 so ghana is is the coast is the gold coast yeah and so it's a place where ever since the the arrival of the portuguese you have the interface with europeans there is this kind of fascinating synergy and also the forest of what is now ghana is linked to um the lands further north, so the Islamic world too. So this is kind of through the early modern period, there is this kind of interface between the European powers on the coast, the Islamic civilizations to the north, and the various peoples who are kind of moving in to what will become Ghana. And of all these people, the Ashanti are by far the most famous and in terms of building
非洲最古老的足球协会，1920年——所以加纳就是，海岸就是黄金海岸。是的，所以自从葡萄牙人抵达以来，这里就一直与欧洲人有着接触，存在着这种奇妙的协同作用。而且现今加纳的森林还与更北方的土地、也就是伊斯兰世界相连。因此，在整个早期现代，海岸上的欧洲列强、北方的伊斯兰文明以及各种迁入未来加纳领土的部族之间，存在着这种奇妙的交融。而在所有人中，阿散蒂人无疑是最著名的，并且在建立庞大帝国和建造城市方面也是最令人印象深刻的。那么阿散蒂人是从哪里来的呢？好吧，阿散蒂人自己有各种各样的传说。其中一个传说是他们从天而降。另一个传说是他们从地洞里钻出来。好吧。
huge empires and constructing cities, the most impressive. So where did the Ashanti come from? Well, the Ashanti themselves have various traditions. So one of the traditions is that they fell from the sky. Another tradition is that they emerged from holes in the ground. Okay. And another tradition is that they emerged from a lake called Bazomptwe, which James Morris describes as a sinister tree infested mere, which intermittently belched gas and mud from its recesses. And actually, the tradition is that it's not just the Ashanti who come from Lake Bazomptwe, but the entire human race. So what you get with those three traditions is the idea that the Ashanti have always been in Ghana, whether they've fallen from the sky, whether they've emerged from a lake, or whether they've emerged from the ground.
还有一个传说是他们从一个叫巴佐姆特维（Bazomptwe）的湖泊中涌现，詹姆斯·莫里斯将其描述为一个阴森诡异、树木丛生的死水潭，它的深处会间歇性地喷出气体和泥浆。事实上，传说不仅阿散蒂人来自巴佐姆特维湖，整个人类也都源于此。因此，从这三个传说中你可以得出这样一个观点：阿散蒂人一直都在加纳，无论他们是从天而降、从湖里涌出，还是从地下钻出来。
And actually, one of the things that strikes me reading about the Ashanti is the kind of the trace, the echoes of Greek or Roman traditions. I mean, obviously they're completely coincidental, but the Athenians had this idea that they, what they called autochthonous, that they were sprung from the soil and that this gave them a peculiar hold on the land that they lived in. So that was part of the Ashanti tradition. But there is also a tradition that they came from the Savannah to the north. And that is obviously what, likelier than the fact that they came from the the savannah to the north and that is obviously what likelier than the fact that they fell from the sky or that they came from the lake probably and just to uh so the coming from the savannah to the north can you put us um in time a little bit more specifically so
事实上，我在阅读有关阿散蒂人的资料时，打动我的一点是其中蕴含的希腊或罗马传统的痕迹、回响。我的意思是，这显然纯属巧合，但雅典人曾有一种观念，即他们所谓的“本土生长”（autochthonous），认为他们是从泥土中生发出来的，这赋予了他们对所居住土地的某种特殊掌控力。所以这也是阿散蒂传统的一部分。但同时也有一个传统认为他们来自北方的热带草原。而这显然比他们从天而降或从湖里出来的说法要合理得多。为了让我们更具体地了解时间上的概念，
when are we talking about probably over the course of the middle ages right that's quite a long period yeah i i mean because because there are no real written records about it. The archaeology is difficult because there's rainforest everywhere. So it's difficult to really say anything more certain than the fact that various peoples, various groupings are migrating into this region and indeed over the whole of all along know, all along the coast, not just into Ghana. Over the course of the Middle Ages. And with the coming of the Portuguese, you start to get a degree of state building because the Portuguese are buyers for slaves and for gold. Yeah, yes.
我们大概在谈论什么时候？可能是在中世纪期间，对吧？那是一个相当长的时期。是的，我的意思是——因为没有关于它的真正文字记录。由于到处都是热带雨林，考古工作十分艰难。所以除了各种各样的人群、不同的部族在这一地区以及整个海岸线——不仅是加纳——在中世纪期间不断迁徙这一事实之外，很难再做出更确切的断言。随着葡萄牙人的到来，你开始看到某种程度的国家构建，因为葡萄牙人是奴隶和黄金的买家。没错，是的。
And so a kind of international process of exchange is starting to build up and you need structures in place to be able to ship these things to the coast yes and then to sell them and then to regulate their trade or whatever i suppose exactly and so by the 17th century there is this uh this people this empire called the denkira and they are occupying the Gold Coast in Ghana and the kind of region inland. And they are the dominant power. And there are various kind of other peoples who are subordinate to them. And among these people are the people who will become the Ashanti. I'm going to call them the Ashanti throughout, but they only get to be called the Ashanti later on for a reason that we'll come to. So by the 17th century, an Ashanti state is starting
因此，一种国际化的交换过程开始建立起来，你需要建立相应的结构，以便能够将这些东西运送到海岸，是的，然后将它们售出，然后规范它们的贸易之类的，我想是的。没错，所以到了17世纪，出现了这样一个人民、这样一个帝国，叫做登基拉（Denkyira），他们占据了加纳的黄金海岸以及内陆地区。他们是占统治地位的力量。有各种其他部族臣服于他们。在这些人当中，就包括了后来成为阿散蒂人的族群。我自始至终都会称他们为阿散蒂人，但他们直到后来才被称为阿散蒂人，原因我们稍后会讲到。因此，到了17世纪，一个阿散蒂国家开始在登基拉的更广泛帝国内部孕育。
to incubate within the broader empire of the Denkira. And there are all kinds of stories told about this process that for anyone familiar with Greek or Roman mythology would be familiar. So they talk about how their state is founded by two twins called Twm and Antwi. And the kind of echoes of Romulus and Remus there are, you know, suggestive. Because these are, I guess, kind of primal legends. There are only so many origin stories that you can construct. But what's clear is that by the 17th century, a bit like the Denkira further south, the people who will become the Ashanti are starting to consolidate. And again, it's basically, I think, because with the introduction of large quantities of iron,
关于这个过程流传着各种各样的故事，对于任何熟悉希腊或罗马神话的人来说都会觉得似曾相识。例如，他们讲述他们的国家是由名叫特姆（Twm）和安特维（Antwi）的两兄弟创立的。这里罗慕洛斯和雷穆斯的痕迹……可以说是耐人寻味。因为这些，我想，都属于原始传说。你能构筑的起源故事毕竟只有那么多。但很明显的是，到了17世纪，有点像更南边的登基拉，未来将成为阿散蒂人的部族开始走向巩固。再次强调，这基本上是因为随着大量铁器的引入，
it's possible for them to start clearing villages. So you start to get this pattern of very thick jungle and open patches where the soil is kind of very red. And that means that they can start to plant crops. And this is a period in the 17th century when the produce of the Americas is starting to be introduced, and particularly maize. And so I remember when we did our episodes on Portugal, somebody on Twitter said, I hope you're going to talk about how the Portuguese introduced maize into Africa and how this became the staple crop. And we didn't, did we? But no, we didn't. I mean, did the staple crop and we didn't did we but no we didn't i did well because i didn't i mean did you know that i didn't know i didn't i didn't know that so this is our opportunity to uh to make amends for that um but it's it's not so it's not just maize that's being introduced it's avocados tomatoes pineapples oranges all that kind of stuff they
他们得以开始开垦村庄。于是你开始看到这种模式：极其浓密的丛林中点缀着土壤呈鲜红色的开阔斑块。这意味着他们可以开始种植农作物。17世纪正值美洲农作物开始引入的时期，尤其是玉米。所以我记得当我们制作关于葡萄牙人的节目时，推特上有人说，我希望你们能谈谈葡萄牙人是如何将玉米引入非洲并使其成为主食的。我们当时没讲，对吧？不，我们没讲。我是说，是不是主食我们没讲，对吧？不，我们没讲。我知道吗？因为我不知道，我是说，你知道吗？我不知道，我真的不知道。所以这是我们借此机会弥补遗憾的好时机……但不仅是玉米被引入，还有牛油果、西红柿、菠萝、橙子所有这些东西，它们
come from america's yeah i didn't know that, Tom. Well, this is an education, Dominic. But you will know that, of course, that the other thing is the gold. Yeah, hence the Gold Coast. Yeah, so even if the people who will become the Ashanti are being obliged to kind of hand gold over to their superiors, to their masters on the coast, the Denkira, they're still getting a bit of it. So the fruits of that is starting to percolate back. And basically by the 1670s, they're kind of on the move, but they're still not really ready to make a pitch for independence, still less for conquest. So in 1680, they have a king who gets killed in battle. And there's a rather sad entry in history that was published in Ghana in the 1970s that said he was buried in an area close to the present day Barclays Bank, but his head was taken away by the Denkira. So that was rather sad. And a kind of reminder of the fact that this is a very
都来自美洲。是的，我以前不知道，汤姆。好吧，这真是一堂生动的课，多米尼克。但你肯定知道，另一件重要的事就是黄金。对，所以才叫黄金海岸。是的，所以即便未来将成为阿散蒂人的部族被迫将黄金上交给他们在海岸上的上级、他们的主人登基拉，他们自己还是能分到一点的。因此，这方面的果实开始回流。基本上到了17世纪70年代，他们开始有所行动，但他们仍然没有真正准备好去争取独立，更不用说征服了。所以在1680年，他们的一位国王在战斗中阵亡。在加纳19世纪（注：原文19世纪，此处按常识或上下文保留）出版的历史书中有一条相当令人伤感的记录，上面写着他被埋葬在现今巴克莱银行附近的一个区域，但他的头颅被登基拉人拿走了。这未免太凄凉了。这也提醒人们，这是一个极其
dangerous world where attempts at rebellion against Imperial Labour Lords are not going to go down well. Although interestingly, you talked about battles battles partly because so much of the areas is as you said thick dense forest presumably these battles are quite small scale by early modern european standards are they yes but as we will see that tends to change under the ashanti right who one of their slogans is that they have teeming thousands. So they are very proud of the enormous numbers of warriors that they can call upon. Anyway, so the guy who's buried close to Barclays Bank
危险的世界，对帝国劳动领主的叛乱企图是绝对不会有好下场的。尽管有趣的是，你刚才谈到了战斗——部分原因是因为正如你所说，很多地方都是厚重的密林，按早期现代欧洲的标准来看，这些战斗大概规模都比较小吧？是的，但正如我们将看到的，在阿散蒂人的带领下，这种情况往往会发生改变。他们的一句口号就是他们拥有数以千计的兵力。因此，他们对能够调动的庞大武士数量感到非常自豪。无论如何，那个被埋在巴克莱银行附近
and whose head gets taken away, he was a guy called Abira Yeboah, and he has a nephew called Osei Tutu. And he is the guy who is commemorated by the Ashanti as the founder of their greatness. He's the Cyrus the Great. Yes. And again, there are kind of echoes of maybe more biblical legends. So the story is that his mother was barren for many, many years, couldn't have a child. And then she goes to the shrine of a very powerful river and
且头颅被拿走的人，名叫阿比拉·耶博阿（Abira Yeboah），他有一个外甥叫奥塞·图图（Osei Tutu）。他被阿散蒂人尊为他们伟业的奠基人。他就是居鲁士大帝。是的。同样，这里也有点像更具《圣经》色彩的传说。故事是这样的：他的母亲多年不孕，无法生育。然后她去了一条非常强大的河流的神龛，
prays to the God there. And miraculously, she becomes pregnant. So that's a kind of staple of biblical stories of prophets. So he is given as a hostage to the Denkira. And this is a bit like, I guess, Philip of Macedon going to Thebes you know he's treated quite well you know he's treated as a prince he's he's brought up oh you know a bit like i don't know barbarians going to the court of consented april he's he's brought up by the denkira in their ways um and in fact he ends up as a shield bearer to the king so this is a great honor and this clearly gives him the chance to study the way that the denkira fight so he's studying the denkira so it's very philip of macedon because that's very yes philip were studied the themans didn't he um and used his knowledge and that's
向那里的神明祈祷。奇迹般地，她怀孕了。所以这可以说是《圣经》中先知故事的常见套路。于是，他被当作人质送给了登基拉。这有点像，我猜，马其顿的菲利普去底比斯那样。你知道的，他受到了很好的对待，被当成王子对待，他被培养……哦，你知道的，有点像野蛮人去孔森特·阿普尔（Consented April，此处疑为地名或人名误读）的宫廷那样，他被登基拉按照他们的习俗抚养长大。事实上，他最终成了国王的盾牌手，这是一种极大的荣誉，这显然让他有机会研究登基拉人的作战方式。所以他在研究登基拉，这简直太像马其顿的菲利普了，因为菲利普研究过底比斯人，不是吗？并且利用了他的知识，这
fascinating yeah or say arminius the uh the the german auxiliary who ends up wiping out the three legions um a virus yeah so it's a standard kind of imperial technique and the denkira are clearly doing it however i'll say tutu is a naughty boy and he gets embroiled in a in a sex scandal when one of the princesses gets pregnant. There is much to do and he has to run away. So he escapes. And he's now very much on his uppers because he's being hunted by the Denkira. He can't go back. He'd take up his princely status. Seems like he's burned his bridges.
太迷人了。是的，或者就像阿米尼乌斯（Arminius）——那个最终消灭了瓦鲁斯三个军团的日耳曼雇佣兵……所以这是一种标准的帝国统治技术，登基拉人显然在这么做。然而，奥塞·图图是个调皮的小伙子，他卷入了一场性丑闻，其中一位公主怀孕了。这引起了轩然大波，他不得不逃跑。所以他逃走了。由于遭到登基拉人的追捕，他现在可以说是山穷水尽。他回不去了，无法恢复他王子的身份。看起来他已经自断后路了。
But then he meets a remarkable man called Okonfo Anokye. So if I'll say Tutu is King Arthur, Okonfyo Anokye is Merlin or Gandalf. He is a man who has deep, deep command of magic. And the story is that he was born with the white tail of a cow in one hand and totem poles in the other. And these are signs of his remarkable destiny. And it probably won't surprise you to learn that his mother, who had a peculiarly coloured hand,
但随后他遇到了一个奇特的人，名叫奥孔福·阿诺基（Okonfo Anokye）。如果说奥塞·图图是亚瑟王，那奥孔福·阿诺基就是梅林或甘道夫。他是一个对深邃的魔法有着极高造诣的人。传闻他出生时，一只手握着牛的白尾巴，另一只手拿着图腾柱。这些都是他注定不凡命运的征兆。你大概不会感到意外的是，他的母亲有一只颜色奇特的手，
had been executed by the King of Denkira as a witch. She had a peculiarly coloured hand. That's the story. That's the story. Yes. What was the colour? Not sure. Maybe a birthmark on her hand? you and your withering skepticism okay fine i'll just believe it i shed a green hand let's crack on so with the backing of this guy with his command of of deep magic i'll say tutu
曾被登基拉国王以女巫的罪名处决。她有一只颜色奇特的手。这就是传说。这就是传说。是的。什么颜色？不太确定。也许她手上有个胎记？你呀，总是带着这种消极的怀疑态度。好吧，行吧，我姑且相信。我猜是一只绿手，我们继续吧。所以有了这个精通高深魔法的家伙的支持，奥塞·图图
is able to start thinking well i'm going to get my own back on the Denkira and I'm not only going to get my own back, I'm going to take them over. And he recognises that to do that, he has to forge a single people out of the many different kind of tribal entities, different villages, different groupings that are scattered over the forest. forest and each grouping that the head of each grouping brilliantly the marker of his power is a stool okay they're absolute masters of uh woodwork in fact their craftsmen are are sensational and so the stools are often beautifully you know the the more beautiful the stool the more prestigious uh you are but um basically there can be only one and so um a confo innocue burns all the stools of all the uh you know all the various tribal leaders he
开始盘算着：我要向登基拉人复仇，我不仅要复仇，我还要吞并他们。他意识到要做到这一点，他必须将散落在森林各处的众多不同部族实体、不同村庄、不同群落锻造成一个单一的民族。而且，每个族群首领的权力标志竟然是一个凳子，好吧。他们在木工方面简直是绝对的大师，事实上他们的工匠简直妙笔生花（叹为观止），因此这些凳子通常都做工精美。凳子越精美，你的地位就越尊贵。但是，基本上只能有一个赢家。所以，奥孔福·阿诺基烧毁了所有这些部落领袖的凳子，
incinerates them as a marker that there can be only one and then a spectacular miracle there are sacrifices are performed and the blood steams up to the sky. Sacrifices of animals, presumably. Well, possibly or possibly not. We'll come to that later. Okay. Yeah. The drums quicken and out of the blood of the sacrifices, a black cloud seems to gather.
他将它们付之一炬，以此作为只能存在一个最高权力的标志。接着，一个壮观的奇迹发生了：举行了献祭仪式，鲜血直冲云霄。献祭的显然是动物。嗯，可能吧，也可能不是。我们稍后再说。好吧。是的。鼓声加快了节奏，从祭品的鲜血中，一团黑云似乎凝聚了起来。
And it's not immediately obvious to people. And then, you know, only a few kind of pointing out saying, what's this cloud? And then it gets thicker and thicker and thicker, blacker than a thundercloud. And then thunder starts to rumble from out of it. And then thick white dust emerges from the cloud and then falling very, very slowly, turning like a seed in a breeze, know dropping from a tree do you know what descended what what appeared is it a stool it is a stool dominic and it glints with gold and yet it's not entirely made of gold so it's an extraordinary thing because below the gold it is
起初人们并没有立刻看清。然后，只有少数人指着喊道：“这是什么云？”接着这团云变得越来越厚，比雷雨云还要黑。紧接着，轰隆隆的雷声从云中传出。然后，浓密的白色尘埃从云中涌现，极其缓慢地飘落，像微风中的种子一样旋转，从树上飘落……你知道有什么降临了吗？什么出现了？是一个凳子吗？没错，多米尼克，它闪烁着金光，但又并非完全由黄金制成。这是一件极其非凡的物件，因为在黄金下面，
that there is exquisitely fabulously carved wood it fell slow, you know, like this kind of seed. Drops, it drops, it drops. And then do you know into whose lap it falls? King Arthur. Yeah, Osei Tutu falls into his lap. And this is a sign. And there's no doubt that this happened, right, Tom? I mean, this absolutely happened.
有着精美绝伦的木雕。它缓缓下落，你知道的，就像那种种子一样。不断下落，下落，下落。然后你知道它落在了谁的膝头吗？亚瑟王。是的，落在了奥塞·图图的膝头上。这就是一个神迹。毫无疑问，这件事确实发生了，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，这绝对是发生了的。
This absolutely happened, as also is the next thing that happened, because Akamfo Onokye takes the stool and he puts it down, and then he does what I think anyone in this situation would do, which is to get an albino to sit on it. Obviously, obviously. And the albino man just vanishes. He just goes like that, and he's gone. And he vanished.
这绝对是发生了，接下来发生的事也同样如此。因为奥孔福·阿诺基拿起这个凳子把它放下，然后他做了我认为任何处在这种情况下的人都会做的事——找一个白化病人坐上去。理所当然，理所当然。而那个白化病男子就这样凭空消失了。他就像这样一坐，人就没了。他就这么消失了。
He sat on the stool and vanished. Yes. And the reason for this is that he's been swallowed up by the stool and has given the stool his soul. So now the stool has a soul. Of the albino. Yeah. It's a bit like the wishing chair in Enid Blyton that had a soul. This is now the soul of this new people that has been forged by this.
他坐在凳子上然后就消失了。是的。原因在于他被凳子吞噬了，并将自己的灵魂赋予了凳子。所以现在这个凳子拥有了灵魂。那个白化病人的灵魂。对。这有点像伊妮德·布莱顿（Enid Blyton）笔下那个有灵魂的许愿椅。现在这成为了由这群人刚刚锻造出的新民族的灵魂。
Yeah. And so the stool is the golden stool it's called the the sicker door coffee the golden stool created on a friday and so this is now the great it's more than an emblem because it has this living soul uh and from that point on dominic no albino man was ever put to death in the shanty empire oh that's a nice so that's a nice touch yeah um so so they've got that they've got've got the golden stool created on a Friday now. So that's tremendous. But now they need a capital.
对。所以这个凳子就是金凳子，被称为“锡卡多科菲”（Sika Dwa Kofi），是在星期五创造的金凳子。所以现在这是伟大的……它不仅仅是一个象征，因为它拥有一个活生生的灵魂。从那一刻起，多米尼克，再也没有一个白化病男子在阿散蒂帝国被处死。哦，这倒是个不错的……这真是一个不错的人性细节。是的，所以……所以他们有了这个在星期五创造的金凳子。这太了不起了。但现在他们需要一个首都。
And so Osetutu does this in a very sensible way. He plants a tree in three locations and he waits to see which one is going to grow the fastest. And the tree that grows the fastest is a place that comes to be called Kumase. And so this becomes the capital. And this is the place that Bowditch will come, who described it in the passage that you first read. So they've got the stool, now they've got the capital, now they need an army. And what happens next is very, very Spartan. So if I say Tutu is a bit
于是奥塞·图图用了一个非常明智的方法来解决这个问题。他在三个不同的地点各种了一棵树，然后等待看哪一棵长得最快。长得最快的那棵树所在的地点就被命名为库马西（Kumase）。于是这里便成了首都。这也是鲍迪奇将要到达的地方，他在你刚才朗读的段落中描述过这里。所以他们有了金凳子，现在有了首都，接下来他们需要一支军队。接下来的事情非常有斯巴达的风格。如果说奥塞·图图有点
like King Arthur, he's also a bit like Lycurgus, the guy who establishes the Spartan constitution and turns them into a kind of great war machine. What he does is to drill them and to make them kind of professional. Their entire focus is going to be war. And because they're drilled, they can kind of maneuver. And again, a bit like the Spartans, a bit like the Zulu, they're very, very adept at holding a center and then kind of like the Zulus called the bullhorns kind of curling around and flanking. Enveloping their opponents. Yeah. And the Ashanti compare their army to a porcupine because, you know, it's kind of the spike bristling with spears. But also with guns because they are, you know, it's not just spears.
像亚瑟王，那他也有点像莱库古（Lycurgus）——那个建立斯巴达宪法并将其变成强大战争机器的人。他所做的事就是对他们进行严格的训练，让他们变得职业化。他们的全部重心都将是战争。正因为经过了训练，他们能够进行机动作战。同样，有点像斯巴达人，有点像祖鲁人，他们非常擅长坚守中路，然后像祖鲁人所说的“牛角阵”一样迂回包抄。包围对手。是的。阿散蒂人将他们的军队比作豪猪，因为你知道的，它浑身布满长矛，蓄势待发。但不仅是长矛，
It's absolutely guns. They're practicing with guns. They're sourcing guns from the coast. As I say, are they trading directly with the Portuguese as well, or do they have to go through their imperial overlords for that? It's not entirely clear. As I say, I'm not entirely on top of the trade mechanics of this, and I'm not entirely on top of exactly when it is that this war machine becomes fully equipped with rifles. But basically, Dominic, the key is it's very, very frightening and very, very menacing.
绝对还有枪支。他们在使用枪支进行训练。他们从海岸获取枪支。正如我所问的，他们是直接与葡萄牙人进行贸易，还是必须通过他们的帝国宗主国来购买？这一点并不是十分明确。正如我所说，我并不是完全精通其中的贸易机制，我也不是完全清楚这支战争机器究竟是在什么时候全面装备了步枪。但基本上，多米尼克，关键在于它非常非常可怕，极具威慑力。
Okay, I'll bear that in mind. And essentially, the point comes where they think we're ready to take on the Denkira and to throw the Denkiran yoke off. But to begin with, I'm afraid to say it goes very badly for them. Fortunately, however, Nokia is able to step in and do his magic stuff. So he uses his magic to secure the defection of various Denkiran generals. So they come over with their their troops um and the other thing that he does is very cool is that um he turns himself into a vulture and he scatters the the body parts of one of the uh one of one of their own generals who's fallen in battle um uh
好吧，我记下了。基本上，时机成熟了，他们认为自己已经准备好对抗登基拉人并摆脱登基拉人的枷锁。但一开始，我很遗憾地说，战局对他们极其不利。不过幸运的是，阿诺基能够介入并施展他的魔法。因此他利用魔法确保了多名登基拉将军的叛变。于是他们带着部队投奔过来……而他做的另一件非常酷的事情是，他把自己变成了一只秃鹫，把一名在战斗中阵亡的他们自己的将军的尸体碎片，
scatters it all over the enemy oh my god that was very off-putting yeah it is off-putting. Yeah, it is off-putting. And it's not good for the Denkirin morale at all. And even more impressively, he shits in the eye of the enemy general. In his capacity as a vulture. Yes. Yeah, I mean, yeah, of course. I mean, he wouldn't. And so the net effect of this is that at a place called Fayasi, they win a tremendous victory.
散落到敌人阵营的到处。哦天哪，这太让人倒胃口了。是的，确实很倒胃口。是的，这太倒胃口了。这对登基拉人的士气打击极大。更让人叹为观止的是，他在敌人将军的眼睛上拉了一梭子（拉了屎）。以秃鹫的身份？是的。是的，我的意思是，当然了。他当然会这么做。所以这一切的净效应就是，在一个叫做法亚西（Fayasi）的地方，他们赢得了巨大的胜利。
They basically wipe out the Denkira. And the Denkiran king, he was so confident of victory that he wasn't even in the battle. And he was off playing a kind of chess a bit further back. And so he gets captured red-handed. And he gets brought before, I say, Tutu. And he behaves very, very well, very bravely. He embraces, willingly embraces death.
他们基本上全歼了登基拉人。而登基拉国王对胜利充满信心，甚至都没有亲自参战。他在后方不远处玩着某种类似棋的游戏。于是他当场被捕，被带到奥塞·图图面前。他的表现非常出色，非常勇敢。他坦然地、甘愿地迎接死亡。
And he says, my crown is lost. My empire is lost because of war. And in the Tui language, Asha means war. And Ti apparently means because of. I'm not pretending I'm in any way familiar with the language if you have any ghanaian listeners i i apologize for my how does it compare with your portuguese tom i think slightly better i think slightly better but you put so you put uh and t together you get a shanty so a shanty literally means because of war. So it's an empire.
他说：“我的王冠失去了。我的帝国失去了，因为战争（because of war）。”在特威语（Twi language）中，“Asha”的意思是战争。而“Ti”显然意思是“因为”。我可没假装自己对这种语言有多熟悉，如果你有加纳听众的话，我为我的发音道歉……这跟你的葡萄牙语比起来怎么样，汤姆？我觉得稍微好一点，我觉得稍微好一点。所以你把“Asha”和“Ti”放在一起，就成了“Ashanti”（阿散蒂）。所以阿散蒂字面上的意思就是“因为战争”。因此这是一个帝国。
The very name of it is expressive of military power. And so the Danquean king dies saying, I die because of war, you know, Ashanti. So the king gets his head chopped off, and then he gets his body parts get divided up, and they get kind of scattered all over this emergent empire. And again, this is strong stuff. So the Ashanti are born. The Ashanti are born.
它的名字本身就彰显着强大的军事力量。于是登基拉国王在临终前说：“我因战争而死，也就是阿散蒂。”接着国王的头颅被砍了下来，然后他的身体各部分被分割开来，并被散落在这个正在崛起的帝国的各地。这手段确实够硬核。于是，阿散蒂诞生了。阿散蒂诞生了。
And basically, as the Denkirans had ruled the people who become the Ashanti, so now the Ashanti are ruling the Denkirans. And this gives them direct access to the coast. Yeah. And so this is all entirely good news. Excellent. And I'd like to think there are more delights coming in the second half. Are there? Lots.
基本上，正如登基拉人曾经统治那些未来成为阿散蒂人的部族一样，现在阿散蒂人开始统治登基拉人了。这让他们能够直接通往海岸。是的。所以这全都是绝对的好消息。太棒了。我希望下半场还会有更多的精彩内容。会有吗？有很多。
Yes. Brilliant. Lots. Great. All right. We'll see you after the break. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
太棒了。有很多。太好了。好的，我们休息一会儿再见。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐之余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八盒八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，向你揭示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场活动门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
So, welcome back to The Rest Is History. we are talking about the ashanti and tom the ashanti have been born because of war what happens next they've got their empire uh presumably it's strength to strength is it yeah they just they because their army is so efficient much more efficient than the denkiran army had been and so that now they've got the preponderance, they can just basically swallow everyone else up. And so they swallow up more and more peoples, more and more kingdoms, and they established this huge empire across much of what is now Ghana.
欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在谈论阿散蒂人，汤姆，阿散蒂人因战争而诞生，接下来发生了什么？他们拥有了自己的帝国……大概是蒸蒸日上吧？是的，他们……因为他们的军队极其高效，比登基拉军队高效得多。所以现在他们占据了压倒性优势，基本上可以把其他所有人都吞并掉。因此，他们吞并了越来越多的人民、越来越多的王国，并在现今加纳的大部分地区建立了这个庞大的帝国。
So can you give us any dates? Yeah, so we're now into the 18th century. We're into the 18th century now. I would guess we're talking 1730s, something like that. So to give that a bit of context for British listeners, so this is the period of the ascendancy of Sir Robert Walpole, the first prime minister, the Industrial Revolution, I suppose. And meanwhile, in what is now gone of the Ashanti Empire,
那么你能给我们提供一些具体的日期吗？好的，我们现在进入了18世纪。我们现在进入了18世纪。我猜我们在谈论1730年代左右，诸如此类的时间。为了给英国听众提供一点背景，这正是罗伯特·沃波尔爵士（第一任首相）执政的鼎盛时期，也是工业革命时期，我想是的。与此同时，在现今加纳的阿散蒂帝国，
it's kind of strengthening its grip. That's basically the picture, isn't it? Yeah, I mean, I suppose it's the period out in the broader world when the British are starting to come to power. And this is going to be quite an important part of the story because the British, along with the French, the Dutch, the Portuguese, they all have kind of trading ports, forts along the Gold Coast. But it's over the course of the 18th century
它正在巩固其统治。基本上就是这幅图景，对吧？是的，我的意思是，我想这是更广阔的世界中英国人开始走向权力的时期。这将成为故事中非常重要的一部分，因为英国人以及法国人、荷兰人、葡萄牙人，他们都在黄金海岸沿岸拥有贸易港口和堡垒。但正是在18世纪的过程中，
that the British start to monopolise that. So the other European powers start to fade away. So by the 19th century, it's basically under British control. And that's going to be a very important part of the story later on. But because those European powers are there, the Ashanti can now profit directly from the trade in gold and the trade in slaves. So it's gold and slaves, and that's the underpinning of their power. And it makes them very, very rich. And it enables them to fashion the incredibly sophisticated society that Bowditch sees when he comes at the beginning of the 19th century. Right, the umbrellas, the wolf's heads,
英国人开始垄断这一地区。其他欧洲列强开始逐渐淡出。所以到了19世纪，这里基本上处于英国的控制之下。这将是后来故事中非常重要的一部分。但正因为这些欧洲列强在那里，阿散蒂人现在可以直接从黄金和奴隶贸易中获利。所以是黄金和奴隶，这是他们权力的支柱。这让他们变得极其富有，并使他们能够打造出鲍迪奇在19世纪初来到这里时所看到的那个极其复杂的社会。没错，那些雨伞、狼头，
all that stuff. Yeah. And so the umbrellas and all that kind of stuff. The Ashanti kings employ Muslims from the north to kind of run their bureaucracy because they're obviously literate. Yeah. But they themselves are not interested in that. And so they need markers of status because this is actually a very sophisticated political system. And it's quite an oppressive system. So there are, you know, there are you know there are spy the kings employ spies everywhere they're kind of constantly checking reporting back to the king
所有这些东西。是的，雨伞和所有这些物件。阿散蒂国王雇佣来自北方的穆斯林来管理他们的官僚机构，因为他们显然识字。但国王他们自己对这些并不感兴趣。因此他们需要地位的标志，因为这实际上是一个非常复杂的政治体系。而且这是一个相当压迫的体系。到处都是……你知道的，国王到处安插密探，他们不断地核查并向国王汇报
what's going on but because it's non-literate it's it's dependent on visual markers of status right uh and and so this is very important and so all the kind of, you know, the staffs, the swords, the gold pectorals, all that kind of stuff, you know, these aren't randomly chosen. They are as significant as similar such things would be in, say, a Byzantine court. So this is the extraordinary civilization that Bowditch and the British come across in the early 19th century. And when you say come across, Tom, just a quick question. So the Europeans are meeting the Ashanti on the coast? They are. The Ashanti control that trade, but the Europeans have not yet
情况进展。但因为这是个非文字社会，它依赖于视觉上的地位标志，对吧？……因此这非常重要。所以所有这些种类繁多的手杖、宝剑、黄金胸饰等，都不是随机选择的。它们的重要性不亚于拜占庭宫廷中同类物品的象征意义。这就是鲍迪奇和英国人在19世纪初遇到的非凡文明。当你遇到他们时，汤姆，有个简单的问题。欧洲人在海岸上与阿散蒂人会面？他们确实如此。阿散蒂人控制了那里的贸易，但欧洲人尚未
really penetrated into the interior. Is that right? Exactly. By and large? Yeah, exactly, because it's dense, dense forest, and the Ashanti are very intimidating. So it's a kind of dangerous thing to do. But by 1820, the first British consul arrives in Kumasi.
真正深入内陆。是这样吗？完全正确。基本上是吗？是的，完全正确，因为那里是密集的雨林，而且阿散蒂人非常令人生畏。所以深入内陆是一件相当危险的事情。但到了1820年，第一位英国领事抵达了库马西。
So the British Empire is starting to slightly spread its wings. Yes. And the British have a very ambivalent attitude towards the Ashanti. Because on the one hand, they find it hugely, hugely impressive, as you could tell from the passage of Bowditch's account that you read. So, Comarcy is a very well-planned capital. It's very clean. Its streets are very spacious. British observers are hugely impressed by the toilets, which they say every house has.
所以大英帝国开始微微展翅高飞了。是的。英国人对阿散蒂人有着非常矛盾的态度。一方面，他们发现这个帝国极其、极其令人印象深刻，正如你所朗读的鲍迪奇记录片段中所能看出的那样。所以库马西是一个规划得非常好的首都。它非常干净。街道非常宽敞。英国观察员对那里的厕所印象深刻，他们说每栋房子都有。
They're kind of flushed out daily with boiling water. There's a daily litter collection. It's very impressive. And there are buildings in Kumasi of a kind that Europeans would be impressed by. So there's a palace built of stone that was built in 1822. The doorways, the windows are sheathed in so it's it's a kind of really very very very impressive the laws are quite exacting so uh no one is allowed to whistle no one's allowed to smoke a pipe and do you know the penalty for sneezing death death yeah death for sneezing
它们每天都用开水冲洗。这里有每日垃圾清理。这非常令人印象深刻。库马西有一些会让欧洲人刮目相看的建筑。比如一座建于1822年的石头宫殿。门口和窗户都包着……所以它确实是一个非常、非常、非常令人印象深刻的地方。这里的法律相当严苛：没有人被允许吹口哨，没有人被允许抽烟斗，你知道打喷嚏的惩罚是什么吗？死刑。死刑，是的。打喷嚏就要被处死。
yeah so it's it's no nonsense, sensible policies, law and order. The British Observer is very impressed with the cleanliness of the upper classes. Well, they're not sneezing, I mean, among other things. And every morning they're washing. They're washing themselves with soap and water, and they are perpetually cleaning their teeth. And this is seen as splendid. But the masses, the British complain, are very dirty.
是的，所以这真是雷厉风行、明智的政策，严格的法律与秩序。英国观察员对上流社会的清洁程度印象深刻。嗯，他们不打喷嚏，除此之外。他们每天早晨都在洗漱。他们用肥皂和水清洗自己，并且时刻清洁牙齿。这被视为非常光鲜亮丽。但英国人抱怨说，底层民众非常肮脏。
But, I mean, british are obviously in no position to criticize because you could say exactly the same of britain so i mentioned the the denkir and king playing a game like chess yeah but he gets captured um and this is a game called awari and very popular i gather across central africa particularly associated with the Ashanti who are very, very good at it. They're spectacularly good at working gold, spectacularly good at working wood, as we see with all the various stools and so on. And their architecture is really very, very impressive. The British are inclined to see Africans as savages,
不过，我的意思是，英国人显然没有资格批评，因为你完全可以把同样的话用在英国身上。所以我提到了登基拉国王玩类似国际象棋的游戏，对吧，但他被俘虏了……这是一种叫做奥瓦里（Awari）的游戏，我听说在中非非常流行，尤其与非常擅长此道的阿散蒂人密切相关。他们黄金加工技术极其精湛，木工活也极其出色，我们在各种凳子等物品上都能看到这一点。他们的建筑确实非常、非常令人印象深刻。英国人倾向于将非洲人视为野蛮人，
as people who have no sense of civilization. They cannot project that stereotype onto the Ashanti. The Ashanti are clearly hugely sophisticated, culturally adept people. However, there are also ways in which the British find the Ashanti not just off-putting, I think, but alarming. So you talked about slavery. There is a lot of slavery. And by the 1820s, this is the age of abolitionism in Britain. The Royal Navy is starting to patrol and try and get rid of slavery. And British hostility to the slave trade is obviously not good news for the Ashanti. So that's a source of tension. They're also very, very keen on conquering people.
认为他们没有文明意识。但他们无法将这种刻板印象投射到阿散蒂人身上。阿散蒂人显然是高度复杂、文化精湛的民族。然而，英国人在某些方面不仅觉得阿散蒂人倒胃口，而且感到惊恐。所以你谈到了奴隶制。这里存在大量的奴隶制。到了18世纪20年代，正是英国废奴主义的时代。皇家海军开始巡逻并试图废除奴隶制。英国对奴隶贸易的敌意显然对阿散蒂人来说不是什么好消息。所以这是一个紧张来源。他们还非常热衷于征服其他部族。
And again, the British, with a hilarious display of hypocrisy, disapprove of this. They feel that the Ashanti are altogether too imperial. And there is also the issue of human sacrifice. So you asked about this earlier. Yeah. And I'm aware from having read about, say, the Aztecs, the Mexica, that narratives that Europeans have received. About, yes, can be very loaded, can't they?
同样，英国人以一种滑稽的虚伪表现对此表示不赞同。他们觉得阿散蒂人实在是太具有帝国主义色彩了。此外还有一个关于活人祭祀的问题。所以你刚才问到了这个。是的。根据我对阿兹特克人、墨西加人等的了解，我知道欧洲人收到的那些叙述，
Can be very loaded. And I don't know enough about the anthropology of this to say, but it does seem from the books that I've been reading about this, all of them, some of them were kind of written in the 1890s, right the way up to the 1980s. So I don't know what the latest thinking on this. So if there are people who can correct me on this, I'd be interested to hear it. But basically, human sacrifice kind of lies at the heart of the Ashanti state, because when they're about to go to war with the Denkira, so Andar Setutu, large numbers of warriors volunteer themselves to be sacrificed in order to guarantee victory, it is said. And it's this kind of offering of blood
关于这些仪式的描述可能会带有很强的偏见，不是吗？可能会带有很强的偏见。我对这方面的民族学了解还不够深入，无法妄下定论，但从我阅读过的关于这个主题的书籍来看——其中有些写于18世纪90年代（注：原文如此，可能指19世纪90年代），一直延伸到20世纪80年代——我并不知道对此最新的看法是什么。所以如果有人能在这方面纠正我，我会很感兴趣的。但基本上，活人祭祀某种程度上构成了阿散蒂帝国的核心，因为当他们准备与登基拉人开战时，为了确保胜利，据说有大量的武士主动志愿作为祭品被献祭。正是这种血液的奉献，
that fertilizes the greatness of the Ashanti Empire. The albino bloke. I mean, presumably that's some folk memory of a sacrifice performed at a stall or something. Perhaps. And when kings die, there are a lot of slaves get kind of immolated, rather like the kind of Viking ship burial assumption that the kings should not go into the afterlife without a great train of slaves to follow them. So slaves and criminals, they all get butchered. There is scope there for the British to feel morally superior.
孕育了阿散蒂帝国的伟大。那个白化病小伙子。我的意思是，那大概是对在凳子上或其他地方执行的祭祀的一种民间记忆吧。也许吧。当国王去世时，会有大量奴隶被殉葬，有点类似于维京时代的船葬假设，即国王在前往来世时身边不能缺少庞大的奴隶队伍来服侍他们。因此，奴隶和罪犯都被屠戮。英国人完全可以借此在道德上占据高地。
And I think throughout the 19th century, that is always a key motor for British imperial expansion. Obviously, there's greed, there's a desire to kind of seize control of trade routes, but there is also this kind of sense of moral superiority that is a kind of rocket fuel for for imperial expansion so the sort of counter i mean the example is david lewisting most famously isn't it um yeah so it's sort of people even if even if we might regard it now as hypocritical they at the time want to believe in a civilizing mission i suppose that's true isn't it i mean yes it's not i mean
我认为在整个19世纪，这始终是英国帝国扩张的关键驱动力。当然，其中存在贪婪，有着夺取贸易路线控制权的欲望，但同时也存在这种道德优越感，它成为了帝国扩张的火箭燃料。所以反过来说——我的意思是，最著名的例子就是大卫·利文斯顿（David Livingstone），不是吗？——是的，所以人们——即使我们现在可能认为这很虚伪——当时确实想要相信一种文明使命，我想这是真的，不是吗？我的意思是，是的，这并不是……
they don't regard it themselves as pure hypocrisy do they well no they don't regard it themselves as pure hypocrisy, do they? Well, no, they don't regard it as hypocrisy. They regard slavery as an evil and that they see it as their mission to stamp it out. Yeah. And that's definitely, I mean, it's not just hypocrisy. I mean, it's not just a kind of cover. They passionately believe it. And an example of this is a man called Sir Charles McCarthy, who is the governor of the British territories along the Gold Coast. And he's an interesting... So he's actually Franco-Irish.
他们自己并不认为这是纯粹的虚伪，对吧？嗯，不，他们并不认为这是纯粹的虚伪，对吧？好吧，不，他们不认为这是虚伪。他们将奴隶制视为一种邪恶，并将铲除奴隶制视为他们的使命。是的，绝对如此——我的意思是，这不仅仅是虚伪。我的意思是，这不仅仅是一个幌子。他们对此深信不疑。一个典型的例子就是一个名叫查尔斯·麦卡锡爵士（Sir Charles McCarthy）的人，他是英国在黄金海岸领地的总督。他是一个有趣的人……实际上他是法爱混血（法裔爱尔兰人）。
So I think his father was a French emigre from the Russian Revolution, and his mother, Dominic, was from Cork. So... Ah, very good. Very good stock there. And he's a very, very keen abolitionist. He corresponds with Wilberforce. He's very into all of that. And he feels that what the Ashanti are getting up to is very poor form. And so in 1823, he launches an expedition against them. But he doesn't take as many people as he should because he's complacent and overconfident.
所以我想他的父亲是一位来自俄国革命的法国流亡者，母亲多米尼克来自科克。所以……啊，非常棒。很好的出身。而且他是一个非常非常坚定的废奴主义者。他与威伯福斯通信。他对所有这些都非常热衷。他觉得阿香提人正在做的事情非常糟糕。所以在1823年，他发动了一场针对他们的远征。但他带的人没有应该带的那么多，因为他自满且过于自信。
And at a place called nasa man cow i hope i've pronounced that right he uh he gets ambushed and his head gets chopped off uh and his skull gets taken to uh kamasi and it's lined with gold and it's used as a drinking cup now it so often happens in history doesn't it i mean i'm thinking about all kinds of Bulgars and, you know, it's very petrified. It's very petrified behavior. Very petrified. Yes, it's very, very, very petrified behavior. So that hasn't gone well.
在纳萨曼考这个地方——希望我发音对了——他遭到伏击，脑袋被砍了下来，头骨被带到了库马西，里面镶上了金子，被当成了酒杯。就像历史中经常发生的那样，不是吗？我的意思是，我想到了各种各样的保加利亚人，你知道，这真是太顽固了。这是一种非常顽固的行为。非常顽固。是的，这是一种非常、非常、非常顽固的行为。所以事情进展得并不顺利。
But then it's the Ashanti's turn to underestimate the British because they then attack the Gold Coast wanting to wipe, get rid of the Europeans altogether so that they can control the whole trade. And the British managed to stave off the attack with the help of the Den trade um and uh the british managed to stave off the attack with the help of the denkira so the denkira so there's a kind of tug of war now between the british and the the ashanti over who is going to be the preponderant imperial power and the denkira have decided that they'd rather side with the british than with with the ashanti
但随后轮到阿香提人低估英国人了，因为他们随后进攻了黄金海岸，想要彻底消灭、除掉欧洲人，以便他们能够控制整个贸易。英国人在登基拉人的帮助下勉强挡住了进攻，嗯，英国人在登基拉人的帮助下勉强挡住了进攻，所以登基拉人……所以现在英国人和阿香提人之间有一种拉锯战，看谁将成为占优势的帝国力量，登基拉人决定他们宁愿站在英国人一边，也不愿站在阿香提人一边。
um and so by 1826 the british are able to to basically to force the Ashanti to a score draw. And they do this with the help of Congreve rockets, which are now kind of in their heyday and nothing that the Ashanti have seen before. And so they establish a river is kind of established as the markers between the two empires. And in 1831, that is confirmed as the border. And then over the course of the 19th century, it's trade and war. So the British do start to supply the Ashanti with the kind of the appurtenances of industrial civilization. And because the Ashanti are status obsessed, all these appurtenances take on tremendous kind of significance. They'll even have carriages.
嗯，所以在1826年，英国人基本上迫使阿香提人打成了平手。他们借助了康格雷夫火箭做到了这一点，这种火箭当时正处于全盛时期，是阿香提人从未见过的。因此，一条河流在某种程度上被确立为两个帝国之间的分界线。在1831年，这被确认为边界。然后在整个19世纪，这里充斥着贸易和战争。因此，英国人确实开始向阿香提人提供工业文明的各种附属物。由于阿香提人对地位有着执念，所有这些附属物都具有了巨大的意义。他们甚至会有马车。
There are no horses, but they'll get people to kind of draw them. And there's a British observer who describes going into the Stone Palace and having a look and saying that it's a bit like a gentleman's club, that there are copies of the times kind of scattered around. That seems strange. Yes. So it's a kind of curious mix. But at the same time that trade is. That seems so strange. Yes. So it's a kind of curious mix. But at the same time that trade is going on, wars are being fought. And over the course of the 19th century,
那里没有马，但他们会让人来拉车。有一位英国观察员描述了走进这座石制宫殿并四处张望的场景，他说这有点像绅士俱乐部，到处散落着《泰晤士报》的复印件。这看起来很奇怪。是的。所以这是一种奇怪的组合。但与此同时，贸易正在进行。这听起来太奇怪了。是的。所以这是一种奇怪的组合。但与此同时，贸易正在进行，战争也在打响，在整个19世纪的过程中，
there are actually four more wars. And it's the last three that are really devastating for the Ashanti. Because by this point, Britain is at its imperial industrial heyday. And really the balance of power has shifted so dramatically in the favor of the British. And the Ashanti don't really understand this. They don't really appreciate this.
实际上还有另外四场战争。正是最后三场战争对阿香提人来说是真正具有毁灭性的。因为到了这个时候，英国正处于其帝国工业的全盛时期，权力平衡确实向有利于英国的方向发生了巨大的倾斜。而阿香提人并没有真正理解这一点。他们没有真正意识到这一点。
Because I think the Ashanti see the British as both perfidious and cowardly. And the British see the Ashanti as kind of just terrifying savages who need to be tamed. And neither characterization is a fair one. But by 1872, the Ashanti are still doing this kind of, oh, let's go off and raid the Gold Coast and see if we can conquer it. And this is a foolish thing to be doing in 1872.
因为我认为阿香提人视英国人为背信弃义且懦弱的。而英国人则视阿香提人为需要被驯服的极其恐怖的野蛮人。这两种定性都不是公平的。但到了1872年，阿香提人仍然在做这种事情，哦，让我们去突袭黄金海岸，看看我们能否征服它。在1872年做这件事是愚蠢的。
And so they abortive attack, they get beaten off, and they steal some missionaries and take them off. And the guy who is in charge of reprisals is a man called Sir Garnet Wolseley. I mean, an enormously Victorian general. I mean, the essence of a Victorian general. The moustache, the ramrod back. Yeah. Sir Garnet Wolseley I mean an
因此，他们的进攻流产了，被打退了，他们还绑架了一些传教士。负责报复行动的人是一个名叫加内特·沃尔斯利爵士的人。我的意思是，一个极其典型的维多利亚时代将军。我的意思是维多利亚时代将军的精髓。小胡子，笔直的脊梁。是的。加内特·沃尔斯利爵士，我的意思是，这是一个
absolutely towering figure and in Victorian popular culture and actually Tom you know Henry Morton Stanley um as in Dr Livingston he covered the third Anglo-Oceania war as a war correspondent so I suppose it's the 1870s and by that time you know Britain has really imperialism has become kind of pop culture in a way it has and so the whole thing is done as a as a kind of exemplary it's like a story and yeah and wolsey is aware the whole way through that the eyes of britain are upon him and so he is kind of behaving like the hero of of an exemplary military tale so he he sends an ultimatum to the Ashanti by traction
在维多利亚时代大众文化中绝对高耸的人物，事实上，汤姆，你知道，亨利·莫顿·斯坦利——也就是利文斯通博士的那位——作为战地记者报道了第三次英阿香提战争。所以我想那是1870年代，到了那个时候，你知道，英国帝国主义已经真正变成了某种流行文化，确实如此，所以整件事都被当作一个典范，就像一个故事一样，是的，沃尔斯利一直意识到英国的目光正聚焦在他身上，所以他表现得就像一个英雄般充满模范军事传奇色彩，于是他通过牵引机向阿香提人发送了最后通牒。
engine. Traction engine. Yeah. I mean, it's a tremendous thing. And the Ashanti are hugely unimpressed by it, it has to be said, and they reject the ultimatum. And so Wolsey prepares for battle. And in James Morris's accounts of this war, he has my favorite ever footnote. So he says, Sagarnet was quite certain of victory, but was resigned to the possibility of casualties, soldiers being made to die in action. And oh, Saganit wrote, how fortunate they are who do so, to which Morris attaches this footnote. In the event only 18 had the good luck to be killed. The 55 enjoyed the consolation of dying from disease. So it's, and as that implies, it's a route. The king flees Comarcy.
牵引机。是的。我的意思是，这是一件了不起的事情。必须承认，阿香提人对此无动于衷，他们拒绝了最后通牒。于是沃尔斯利为战斗做准备。在詹姆斯·莫里斯对这场战争的记述中，他有我最喜欢的脚注。所以他说，萨加内特确信胜利，但也对可能出现的人员伤亡逆来顺受，士兵们被迫在战斗中死去。哦，萨加内特写道，那些这样做的人是多么幸运啊。莫里斯为此加上了这个脚注：结果只有18人有幸战死。其余55人则享受了死于疾病的安慰。所以，正如那所暗示的，这是一场溃败。国王逃离了库马西。
His noblemen flee it. Wolseley enters the city and is hugely impressed by it. Very, very struck by the sophistication of the architecture, the cleanliness of the streets, all that kind of stuff. However, there is also a lot that he is appalled by. And there's a brilliant account. So I will read some of the descriptions of what he found. So he found, it is reported, the great death drum decorated with human skulls and thigh bones. The stools that had belonged to the king's ancestors stood near it. And then outside the palace, this account claims, another spot that was visited was the death grove,
他的贵族们逃离了那里。沃尔斯利进入这座城市，并对其印象深刻。对建筑的精致、街道的清洁等等留下了非常非常深刻的印象。然而，也有很多让他感到震惊的地方。这里有一个精彩的记述。所以我将读一些关于他发现的描述。据报道，他发现了一个以人类头骨和大腿骨装饰的大型死亡之鼓。国王祖先的凳子就立在它附近。然后在这个记述声称，在宫殿外面，另一个被参观的地方是死亡树林，
a gruesome hollow in the center of a clump of trees and tall reeds into which the bodies of the victims of human sacrifice were thrown. it was now nearly filled with their remains. So some people argue very bitterly about this now, don't they? They do. Some people say, well, this gives the light to the idea that the British were just evil militaristic bullies. And actually, the Ashanti weren't, you know, they weren't kindly social workers. And we shouldn't present
一个位于树丛和高高芦苇丛中央阴森恐怖的凹地，人祭受害者的尸体就被扔进那里。现在它几乎被他们的遗体填满了。所以现在有些人对此争论得非常激烈，不是吗？确实如此。有些人说，这驳斥了那种认为英国人只是邪恶军国主义霸凌者的观点。事实上，阿香提人也不是什么慈祥的社会工作者。我们不应该用
this in sort of um moralistic good and evil terms in which the British are the bad guys because they're the imperialists and then other people say oh but these accounts of the Ashanti are you know are loaded with uh with prejudice and actually the this is all nonsense and the British are making all this stuff up is there any do you have any sense of whether right i don't know maybe they are i mean as i say i i said earlier i'm not aware of the latest academic thinking on this but these are two empires and empires are founded on violence um and you know the british are more effective in their violence but the ashanti definitely you know i, I mean the whole, you know, they wouldn't have this empire unless they were very violent and
善恶道德主义的术语来呈现这一点，即英国人是坏人，因为他们是帝国主义者；而另一些人则说，哦，但这些对阿香提人的记述充满了偏见，实际上这一切都是无稽之谈，英国人是在捏造这一切。你觉得有这种可能吗？我不知道，也许吧。正如我所说，正如我刚才所说，我不知道关于这方面的最新学术思考，但这是两个帝国，而帝国是建立在暴力之上的。而且，你知道，英国人在运用暴力方面更有效率，但阿香提人绝对，你知道，我的意思是整个，你知道，如果他们不是非常暴力和
intimidating. It's, you know, that's the way empires are. Yeah. And, and, and we'll see is,
具有威慑力，他们就不会拥有这个帝国。你知道，这就是帝国的运作方式。是的，而且，而且，沃尔斯利对此
is appalled by, I mean, he was certainly, he, he is sufficiently appalled by what he finds there to blow it all up. So he lays death charges and then he retreats and the whole thing gets blown up. So, I mean, maybe it's just a random act of vandalism i would have thought it's unlikely
感到震惊。我的意思是，他对在那里发现的东西感到足够震惊，以至于把它们全部炸毁了。所以他安放了炸药，然后撤退了，整个地方都被炸毁了。所以，我的意思是，也许这只是一种随意的破坏行为？我本以为这不太可能。
i mean it is definitely vandalism but i wouldn't thought he'd do it just for the fun of it right maybe he did i don't know i don't know i'm i'm very open to being corrected on this by people who know i mean the truth i suppose uh the truth is when this is absolutely one of those stories isn't it one of these stories of 19th century imperialism that people look at it through tinted spectacles that reflect their own political prejudices well i i mean i think there's a case for saying that perhaps uh you know i talked about how the the british and the shanti don't really understand each other but on another level you might say actually perhaps they they they understand each other better than we are qualified to do now because we are so instinctively anti-imperial you know wolsey admires the ashanti as an imperial people he admires their discipline he admires
我的意思是这绝对是破坏行为，但我不会认为他只是为了好玩才这么做，对吧？也许他真的这么做了，我不知道，我不知道，对于那些知情者的纠正，我非常乐意接受。我的意思是，真相我想，真相是，这绝对是19世纪帝国主义的那些故事之一，人们透过折射他们自身政治偏见的有色眼镜来看待它。好吧，我的意思是，我认为有理由说，也许，你知道我之前谈到英国人和阿香提人如何并不真正理解对方，但在另一个层面，你可能会说，实际上也许他们比我们现在更有资格去理解对方，因为我们如此本能地反帝国主义，你知道，沃尔斯利钦佩阿香提人作为一个帝国民族，他钦佩他们的纪律，他钦佩
their their courage he admires their character he recognizes them you know rather like the british recognize the zulus as worthy adversaries but he is also sufficiently self-confident in his own morality and in the morality of the empire that he represents for it never to cross his mind that blowing up you know the yeah the the sacred capital of of of a people might in any way perhaps be kind of echoing the very behavior that he's condemning yes so there are two more wars 189696, the king, the British grab him, they depose him, and they remove him to the Seychelles. And Baden-Powell is involved in that war, isn't he?
他们的勇气，他钦佩他们的品格，他认可他们（有点像英国人认可祖鲁人是值得尊敬的对手），但他也对自己的道德以及他所代表的帝国的道德充满自信，以至于他从未想过炸毁一个民族的神圣首都可能会在某种程度上呼应他正在谴责的那种行为。是的，还有另外两场战争，1896年，国王，英国人抓住了他，废黜了他，并把他流放到塞舌尔。贝登堡也参与了那场战争，不是吗？
Correct. And this expedition is led by Robert Baden-Powell, who will go on to found the Scouts. So he removes the king, who's a man called Prempeh, and so he goes off to the Seychelles. You know, the worst places to be, I guess. I was about to say, people pay very good money for that these days but then Dominic in um 1900 yeah you have the war of the golden stool so our old friend
没错。这次远征由罗伯特·贝登堡领导，他后来创立了童军。所以他废黜了这位名叫普雷佩的国王，于是他去了塞舌尔。你知道，那大概是最糟糕的去处了。我正想说，如今人们花大钱去那里呢。但在1900年，多米尼克，是的，爆发了金凳子之战，所以我们的老朋友
the golden stool is still very much on the scene very much on the scene the golden stool and does it end with the golden stool is that basically the yes it does it does because because the um the British governor of the gold coast goes to Comarcy and he's offended by, you know, he sees it as a kind of a superstitious totem and he's offended by it. And he says, what must I do to the man, whoever he is, who has failed to give to the queen, who is the paramount power in the country, the stool to which she is entitled? Where is the golden stool? Why am I not sitting on the golden stool at this moment? I am the representative of the paramount power in this country. Why have you relegated me to this chair? Why did you not take the opportunity of my coming to Comarcy to bring the golden stool and give it to me to sit upon? This is an absolutely mind
金凳子依然还在登场，依然活跃在舞台上。金凳子，难道是以金凳子告终的吗？基本上是这样的，是的，确实如此，因为黄金海岸的英国总督去了库马西，他对此感到被冒犯，你知道，他将其视为一种迷信的图腾，并对此感到被冒犯。他说：我该对那个人——无论他是谁——做些什么呢？他未能将这个国家至高无上的权力女王所应得的凳子交出来。金凳子在哪里？为什么我此时此刻没有坐在金凳子上？我是这个国家至高无上权力的代表。为什么你们把我降级到这把椅子上？为什么你们在我来到库马西时没有借此机会把金凳子拿来让我坐上去？这是一个绝对令人匪夷
boggling story. Let me get this right. The British representative demanded to sit on the golden stool. They said no, presumably. Yes. Well, because nobody sits on the golden stool. The shanty king doesn't sit on the golden stool you know the british governor is coming and say i want to sit on the stool it's terrible you can't do that and that triggered a genuine war in which triggers a genuine war yes well because they're incredibly offended i mean it's the most offensive thing you could possibly do did the albino guy die in vain didn Didn't die so some British ass could sit on. Yeah. So, Tom, I mean, yet again, I can see both sides in this story.
思的故事。让我理清一下。英国代表要求坐在金凳子上。他们拒绝了，大概吧。是的。因为没有人能坐在金凳子上。阿香提国王自己都不能坐在金凳子上。你知道，英国总督来了说，我想坐在凳子上。这太可怕了，你不能这么做。这引发了一场真正的战争，引发了一场真正的战争，是的，因为他们受到了极大的冒犯。我的意思是，这是你能做出的最具冒犯性的事情。那个白化病家伙难道是白白死去的吗？他死不是为了让某个英国混蛋能坐上去。是的。所以，汤姆，我的意思是，再次重申，我能看到这个故事的两个方面。
Yeah, I'm just looking at it now. I've just got the Bodleian website up here. Thousands of people died. 3,000 people or something. Yeah, it's extraordinary. And large numbers of the Chanty elite they they get rounded up and taken off the seychelles as well uh and the golden stall is hidden so the british don't get their hands on it and kind of ship it off to the british museum or whatever so you know
是的，我刚刚在看它。我刚刚打开了博德利图书馆的网站。数千人死亡。三千人左右。是的，这太非同寻常了。大量阿香提精英被围捕并带到了塞舌尔，而金凳子被藏了起来，这样英国人就无法染指并将它运到大英博物馆什么的。所以，你知道，
right yeah they're obviously itching to do yes yeah so in the 1920s it's found by um a shanty workman who instead of showing it the respect that they should do they strip it of its gold and this causes of i mean you know fury so there the respect that they should do, they strip it of its gold. And this causes, I mean, you know, fury. So there's demands that they be put to death. But by this point, the British have learned their lesson. They understand, you know, that they're dealing with something, dare I say, sacral. And so they don't consent to have the Ashanti put to death,
对，是的，他们显然急不可耐地想这么做。是的。所以在20世纪20年代，它被一个阿香提工人发现了，他没有表现出应有的尊重，而是剥去了上面的黄金。这引起了，我的意思是，你知道，狂怒。因此有人要求将他们处死。但到这个时候，英国人已经吸取了教训。他们明白，你知道，他们面对的是某种，我敢说，神圣的东西。因此他们不同意将阿香提人处死，
the workmen who've stolen it, but they have sent them into exile. And they issue a formal promise to respect the stool and they and they do crikey and in uh in 1933 uh prempay the second is he's been elected as king a couple of years earlier he returns from the seychelles and he becomes king in the traditional ritual in which the golden stool plays the starring role. But he also becomes the leader of a Boy Scout troop. And so there, perhaps, you have a moment where you see the fusion, the integration of these two great empires, these two sacred traditions meeting and mixing. And to this day, there is an Ashanti king, constitutional monarch.
那些偷金子的工人，而是将他们流放了。他们发布了尊重金凳子的正式承诺，他们确实这么做了。天哪！在1933年，普雷佩二世——他在几年前被选为国王——从塞舌尔归来，并按照金凳子扮演主角的传统仪式成为国王。但他同时也成为了一名童军小队的领袖。所以，在那里，也许你会看到一个时刻，你看到了这两个伟大帝国、这两种神圣传统的融合、整合、相遇和交融。直到今天，仍然有一位阿香提国王，作为立宪君主。
So the ashanti the ashanti kingdom i did not know that yeah so it's it's it's ongoing i think it's a you know it's um it's a remarkable story oh my words i've just looked him up autumn fuo nana osse to to the second yeah so he's named after the founder of the uh he's a Freemason. Tom! I didn't know that. He's the sword bearer of... That's very disappointing. He's the sword bearer of the United Grand Lodge of England. No, I mean, there's all sorts of things going on here, aren't there?
所以阿香提，阿香提王国，我以前不知道这一点。是的，所以它仍在继续。我认为这是一个，你知道的，这是一个非凡的故事。天哪，我刚查了一下他，奥图富奥·纳纳·奥塞·图图二世，是的，所以他是以该组织的创始人命名的……他是一个共济会会员。汤姆！我不知道这一点。他是联合英格兰大总会的持剑者……这太令人失望了。他是联合英格兰大总会的持剑者。不，我的意思是，这里发生了各种各样的事情，不是吗？
I mean, there's Boy Scouts, Freemasons... Yeah. Golden Stools. Yeah. Gully. Yeah. It's all going on. It is all going on.
我的意思是，有童军、共济会……是的。金凳子。是的。沟渠。是的。各种事情都在发生。确实都在发生。
It's very Anglo-ish ante. His jewels were stolen from a hotel in oslo i'm just reading bits of the internet i didn't know that i didn't know that but on the subject of kind of anglo um ashanti fusion i'm sure that this is also why the ghanaian uh football association is so old so 1920 when the golden stool was was recaptured was rediscovered. So, yeah. So anyway, I hope you've enjoyed that. So interesting. So interesting. And as, you know, let's be honest, we're not Ashanti experts by any means,
这非常具有英阿香提风格。他的珠宝在奥斯陆的一家酒店被偷了——我只是在看互联网的碎片信息。我不知道那件事，我不知道那件事。但说到英阿香提融合的主题，我确信这也是为什么加纳足球协会历史如此悠久的原因——1920年金凳子被重新夺回、重新发现时。所以，是的。总之，希望你们喜欢这个故事。太有趣了。太有趣了。而且，正如我们所说，老实说，我们绝不是阿香提专家，
but it's a classic example, isn't it? But it's a classic example of those historical blind spots that people have because, you know, sub-Saharan African history, pre-colonialism is so little known outside Africa, isn't it? Well, it's the lack of written evidence. Lack of written sources, yeah. Which is basically, I guess, why it's only in the early modern period when you start to get European accounts that you have some sense
但这是一个典型的例子，不是吗？但这正是人们所拥有的那些历史盲点的典型例子，因为你知道，撒哈拉以南非洲的历史，前殖民时期的历史在非洲以外是如此鲜为人知，不是吗？嗯，这是因为缺乏书面证据。缺乏书面资料，是的。我想这基本上就是为什么直到近代早期当你开始获得欧洲人的记载时，你才对这些大概一直在涌现的非凡国家
of these extraordinary states that are presumably emerging all the time. We just don't know about them. Fascinating. Well, thank you, Tom. As a great great man would put it that was an absolute tour de force thank you i know i really enjoyed that i really enjoyed that and as we always say the beauty of this series is we get to do um subjects that wouldn't necessarily have occurred to us trapped in our very anglo-saxon kind of mindset so it's fun to do genuinely global history tom genuinely history dominic yes we have all kinds of treats to come so thanks again to tom and bye-bye bye-bye
有了一些概念。我们只是对它们一无所知。太迷人了。好的，谢谢你，汤姆。正如一个伟人所说，那绝对是一次精彩绝伦的展示，谢谢你。我知道，我真的很喜欢。我真的很喜欢。正如我们常说的那样，这个系列的魅力在于我们可以做一些不会自然而然发生在我们这些被困在极具盎格鲁-萨克逊思维方式中的人身上的主题。所以做真正全球性的历史很有趣，汤姆，真正地，多米尼克，是的，我们还有各种各样的精彩内容要呈献，所以再次感谢汤姆，再见。再见。
thanks for listening to the rest is history episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
感谢收听《历史余烬》（The Rest Is History）节目。想要获取早期访问权、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的途径。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。